I think that we are starting to see more
young women getting engaged in law in
business in medicine and hopefully in
politics because it's really important
that woman's voice be heard and
certainly from those of us who have run
won or lost we can provide that
encouragement to throw their hat in the
ring because that is when we will have a
truly representative democracy I think
we're away from having equal
representation but we need to keep
working on getting those numbers up at
getting a critical mass is important
that's at local level congressional
level and I would hope that fairly soon
in my lifetime we will have a woman in
the White House I think that's what a
lot of people are working for and I hope
we will see it soon so my study group is
Thursday afternoons from 4 to 5 30 and
what we have been doing is examining how
people in fact through politics and
other ways can affect change is it
through legislation challenging in the
courts my grass roots and we've had
terrific discussions with Barney Frank
and with some organizers for those who
got the minimum wage raised in
Massachusetts the students will learn a
lot and I think they'll come away
feeling they have some concrete ways
they can help change the world